nothing would make me happier than to
post this clip 14 months from now when
you and J Balvin and Bieber have got a
song that's number one on iTunes and I
may be like yo I was a part of that
process and I know it could happen like
here's why you're an actual artist
[Music]
what's going on that makes me happy
yep and so what's been the best part of
Vayner
I think but I also think it solved if I
also truly believe if people are happy
that eyes are crazy what can I help you
with the community as a whole is the
inspiration I think for me I'm not
easily inspired like I don't I think I'm
I don't know I feel like I'm almost like
I you know how like the batteries have
like the two sides like they're
different like the a beast like I feel
like I'm the reverse I feel like that
already had happened or was hardwired
into me like I've never I don't even
know like I've never been inspired the
way I inspire others I've never I think
it's very interesting
like that's not true like you know I'm
nonprofit events I can get very inspired
where human beings are just doing real
things for life but not in the business
II kind of like not in business not in
like career you know generally what I'm
most inspired by is the hardest emails I
have my inbox which is you know I'm a
single mother of two I've working three
jobs
I read crush it on the night shift of
this do you think I can start a jewelry
brand you know that's just like [ __ ]
right like I'm like you know like people
are complaining about like it's hard to
make more content and I'm like mother
[ __ ] like this you know like this
woman has got like two
these are kids for an hour a day because
she works 21 hours a day not 15 and not
out of like the [ __ ] she's aspiring to
do out of like like providing I'm very
I'm very inspired by people that are
suffocated out of options and still have
the [ __ ] intestinal fortitude to like
like bite their lip put their head down
and [ __ ] try to grind for the next 17
years just to get a vacation one day
that inspires me tremendously because
that's hard yeah
I'm inspired when it's hard I'm not
inspired by what was me I can't find my
passion my you know I'm just not thank
you have a great day no man you know
what yeah there's one thing the reason I
think I did really well I think this
company does really well and this would
be good with an econ background is the
wine world is not consumer centric the
wine world's about the wine world and
that's why they all [ __ ] lose and
very honestly the business world's about
the business world they worry about
themselves not about the actual customer
and that's why companies like Amazon or
people like me win so much because when
you actually are consumer centric so the
more you can help them be consumer
centric care about what people are
pairing wines with how they're drinking
them in what environments in what
packaging not you've the side of the
story is the dog did this or the
malolactic fermentation that or this how
many months got it everybody decides
their story and tries to ram it down the
throat instead of listening so I'll give
you a big piece of advice go out a lot
and go to wine places and listen I won
because I sat behind a register for
years and watched people interact in a
store and then had the ability to
translate that intuition and
understanding into how we interact with
technology the end nice to meet you I'm
Bridget Bridget it's such a pleasure
kind of just wanted to pick your brain
for what 2018 is gonna look like
I heard you say it's gonna be amazing
that's what I want to hear what's so
exciting that's coming down the line I
think I think the world's coming to us
so then and the like just the deal flow
of companies that want us to give
strategies and then creative executions
like people want Facebook videos people
want Alexis skills people want
influencer programs on Instagram
they don't want billboards they don't
want programmatic banner ads I think our
contemporary nature of marketing is
feeling more practical to the biggest
companies in the world not futuristic we
will benefit disproportionately for that
thanks Cort have a great day what a vlog
Kim and I from dinner experience are
talking about pan next year what are the
dates June 1813 22nd we're debating our
overall strategy I'm gonna do a little
business Sunday on Thursday we're
thinking about putting on a series I'm
looking for sponsorship of people that
are trying to get into the marketing
world if you have a SAS product things
of that nature
I'm basically deciding two very
different paths one is gonna require me
creating a you know a four hundred
thousand dollar event
so between sponsorships and dinner
series you know I'm just throwing this
out there and this is obviously for only
1% of the people watching but if you are
trying to tap into the marketing world
or the big brand world and you are a
start-up with SAS products or a service
or things of that amount and from an
international standpoint a lot of
European Watchers right now feel free to
send an email to hear can biz or biz can
actually okay I'll just come up with it
Boehner can at vaynermedia com create it
vein or cam can will spell ill be
spelled to your CIN and then yes at
vaynermedia com if you are looking to
sponsor or you don't waste your time
because it's more valuable to you and
definitely Kim's time we are looking for
sponsors with 25,000 to 400,000 dollar
packages will put on dinners will put on
events but I'm trying I'm gonna decided
next week or so what our strategy is
[ __ ] it let me jam with you guys so see
what happens
on dailyvee over the holidays what we're
doing yeah I'd like you three to get
[ __ ] busy and put out make some
[ __ ] films
sorry how are you man it's a real
pleasure higher than 30 hours
yeah that's beast please sit to your
point it's a smart observation once you
[ __ ] ladder this up to a global
conversation it becomes real [ __ ]
interesting and you've done that with
your brand you took it to a global level
which then lets you play different chess
because I'm sure if we looked at the
[ __ ] score like where your brand sits
in Chile versus where it sits in
Singapore words sits in Detroit they're
gonna just be [ __ ] different matrix
would he do it the way that I do it
where I have people follow me around and
they're just chopping up the content
would you do that Dennis you mean look
I've built my entire thing then it's a
hundred percent for this [ __ ] thing
Instagram snapchat Facebook podcast
Dennis is culture literally as long as
it's to your point scene I know that
Dennis on a Facebook watch and a podcast
gets seen way more than any reality show
execution to produce unlimited amount of
content around Dennis that Dennis gets
to approve for Instagram snapchat
podcasts YouTube that's the [ __ ] game
the end now what's different though of a
reality show or when you do it is you're
always catching everything you're not
scared to be your full self because
you're in charge of post-production
you're just I'm literally myself all the
time because I'm in charge of what pumps
out I'm like iris don't put that in
there done there's no debate so the
control of the [ __ ] content is the
game yeah the reason this will work for
you more than anybody is the truth is
the only thing that [ __ ] wins I'm a
hundred percent one percent you took
attention and you reversed the leverage
in your favor period and the story I
understand it cold when you were doing
it now
now the key though is you what you had
back in the day Dennis was you had
distribution you have people watching
what you need is to control people
watching and the same [ __ ] will happen
again that's all
Hogan was the biggest thing in the
[ __ ] world from 84 to 87 when
everybody's watching he wasn't in 1993
then [ __ ] Breslin came back and
everybody gave a [ __ ] in 96 to 98 and he
was
it's just attention dennis is a top
hundred famous person whenever he has
people actually watching my man where
are you with music like mentally
mentally I'm meaning you want to produce
projects solutely you just need to make
because what's crazy about kind of
talent you have and the status you app
you're just one bar away from everything
changing again that's just crazy to me
right what I don't know and this is the
truth is how fancy you are and what I
mean by fancy is how romantic you are
about [ __ ] my intuition is you are
romantic because you should be
and I want to reframe the romance no I
would say passion you've got it's why
you're gonna win I can see it comes from
and everything you do know I mean you
thinking something isn't quality enough
for you to put your name on it because
you protected it's so well and you're
not realizing it's all upside and you're
seeing it as downside and it comes from
a hundred percent what is that what we
have we have and you know my man I know
and ready and honestly here's my concern
I think they've put you in a cage they
sure David nolley they shortened and you
know what happens when you get in cage
you don't do [ __ ] you just stay in the
box but you're in a cage and I know it
and I'm just trying to make you think of
it as a macro and I know why you're not
because of everything I just said there
is no 77 year old hip-hop icon yet but I
think that's what you are and if you
thought that too
well then you're like [ __ ] I got a lot
of work to do instead of that's what I
did that's a young man's game and I'm on
to being a artist a philanthropist
entrepreneur got it
I don't believe that I think you can
have the number one record in the
country tomorrow stepping out the box
that they put you in that you put
yourself in that you and your man put
yourself in step the [ __ ] out and it
would make me nothing would make me
happier than to post this clip 14 months
from now when you and J Balvin and
Bieber got a song that's number one on
iTunes and I'ma be like yo I was a part
of that process and I know it could
happen like here's why you're an actual
artist you putting out a song that gets
hot that's a foregone conclusion you
just need to get the [ __ ] out of the
jail that everybody put you in and you
and guess what they love you and you
love them that's right but guess what
I got [ __ ] on for not being the wine guy
anymore when I started talking about
business until I didn't talk I'm glad
you came through man
please [ __ ] you both did you understand
yes I'm gonna do something absolutely
well wouldn't that I don't know because
it's [ __ ] hard to like change up here
sometimes I think with the current state
of attention in podcast this is a
question to you as well equally what
excites the [ __ ] out of me with this is
that it's super narrow and what scares
me about the next one is it's too broad
and I think to win on podcast in the
current state it'd probably be very
smart for us to go as narrow as possible
cool hey what what a vlog good day just
have a great pure well meeting everybody
subscribe to pure well virus is killing
it
CID not as much Marcus definitely team
to do better than I did last year
daily resolutions [ __ ] that's a
great [ __ ] question meaning I don't
understand the question
let's go
the thing about but other interesting
things we're trying to get started
you either happen all right blog them
out thinking about it
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]